Luke here with the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel me and my boys we're here in the
illusion chain of Alaska on the shores
of the Bering Sea we're spending the
next four days exploring World War II
battlefields and fishing the deadliest
Waters in all of the United States are
you guys having a good time
[Music]
myself
well we couldn't land in Dutch Harbor
because of weather so we flew four and a
half hours and back where we started one
week later
try it again
[Music]
too
well it took us two tries but we finally
made it to the island of Onalaska
so this is Dutch Harbor on the island of
unalaska
[Music]
this is where the world's largest
halibut was caught over 400 pounds this
is also the home of the reality TV
series Deadliest Catch and during World
War II Dutch Harbor was the site of an
important battle between the Japanese
and the United States
check it out there's a pill box
oh it's so cool
bald eagle just hanging out on that
light pole
me and the boys are staying at the only
Hotel on the island and one of the few
hotels in the United States with World
War II pill boxes in the parking lot
or you could do it that way
hi
all right what do you guys want to eat
on the boat tomorrow
we've got a fishing trip tomorrow so we
got to get a few supplies first
I need a new pair of fishing boots mine
split a hole in them
hmm
here in Onalaska there's a massive
commercial fishing fleet so whenever new
deckhands need gear they come here yeah
they're insulated and they're waterproof
there are tons of Latinos Pacific
Islanders and Asians that come here to
work in the fishing industry so this
supermarket has tons of International
Food
sours up nectar a sangria scenario you
got mango do I chicharrones all right
get this in future owns buttercream Ube
crackers oh yeah High chews yeah you
grab some of those
[Music]
you guys really hungry yeah you sure
you're hungry I'm sure on Wednesday
nights the Grand Illusion hotel has the
best buffet
look at this
sir what are you thinking information so
that when you reach out I have it
let's sit at the table all right
ever since he was a baby he's loved
lemons just eats in my good orange
I think we need to get some of that
dessert
full cookie tower
that was a lot of food 6 30. all right
guys lay down you want me to show you a
tricked it for going to sleep good night
hey Nathan do you want to go to sleep
good night
all right both the boys are out I'll see
you in the morning
guys wake up
wake up
oh yeah
David
oh look at that bad boy
hey boys come on
all right guys we're going fishing we're
keeping it real fishing charters and if
you guys watch our videos you'll know
that me and Tommy did this trip last
year and we just had an amazing time so
we're back here we're gonna give it
another go
so they used to have like
these islands are beautiful rugged but
beautiful
there's some porpoises up ahead
right there
there's a whole bunch of whisker doclets
out there you can only find them here in
the Aleutian chain
there's a puppet
look at all those are Herring right
there look there's a big bait ball of
Herring birds are feeding on them the
puffins are so full of fish they can't
fly away they're just kind of wallowing
like I do after Thanksgiving dinner we
dropping rigs yeah
it's got these big jigs here that we got
two electric reels one for each boy and
I'll go with the conventional
you got one yeah
oh we got a double already oh Nathan
oh yeah
bet on the bottom for 30 seconds
oh taking it I know we only allowed two
there we go
I mean even with the electric reel this
is a massive wrestling match
it's getting close now you're gonna have
to crank it in by hand okay
get in my hand
look at that Cod that is a lovely Cod
that's big oh look at he just he just
barfed up a Harry
that's small I think that's pretty
normal
all right Nate I think that might be
your first specific cause one hand oh
two boys
good luck
oh I can see color down there that
go now I think yours is bigger than
eight
that's too small
all right we drifted off our spot a
little bit so we're gonna reposition the
boat and try again
oh there was something biting that
already
[Music]
feisty little halibut well
let's
well I've just been non-stop action
there we go hey Tommy's got one
oh yes
[Music]
David you hold it I did this sucker that
is a nice hell of it oh
nice oh
wow high five Nathan that's it
congratulations Bud oh man we got a hook
we got a fish on here I've got one
getting bit and we got another one going
in the cooler there you go
oh Tom Tom's got a card
no
currents and wind drifting
spots and we'll hit it until it kind of
cools off then we'll reel up reposition
the boat and drift over it again
oh nice
in it I caught one huh we keeping this
one yep nice fish Tom
oh I'm getting just bite after bite oh
there we go
I see him
what do you think
I mean it is
not a bad double
oh I'm not setting any records but man
that's a nice fish once he got the
throat
there we go hey everyone's got their
first halibut in the boat
oh there's a fish didn't hit the bottom
oh
I got a kelp greenling that is yeah guys
good bait right yeah
the kelp Greenlee yeah
all right got a little piece of that
kelp grilling on the hook here gonna
spike it
oh three rods got fish Tommy's got one
today's it's got one I've got one
oh Nathan nice halibut
oh God
right there just the only catch a lot
I'm letting the
guys down there do you got color
almost every time I hook up the boys
have a double or a triple there's so
much footage I'm missing just because
I'm trying to film and reel and fish at
the same time
oh
sour Chef is one of those fruits that
really doesn't taste like any fruit you
might be familiar with but it's so good
oh we're at a new spot we've been here
15 seconds and we already have a triple
it's pretty on par for Dutch Harbor
all right let's see what you got
oh nice card got it
nice card there Nathan
is it
got another one Nathan I'm a fishing
machine oh
I love this blue one
Nathan do you got another one sheesh oh
that's a league God
oh Nathan that is that is like the
tastiest fish look at the teeth on that
thing that is a big boy
yeah they're like an eel yeah there you
go Nathan that is a gorgeous lean card
really unusual to catch a lean Cod over
in this part of Alaska so that's a
pretty special fish
oh Tommy's got his card then you see
that's
beautiful
barely hooked too
yeah you having fun
confidence
they're probably getting beat up
go go
oh look at that yeah we got a link
oh
God
oh Nathan's got another fish there's a
whale
yeah look at that right there see him
Nathan's got a nice Cod and there's a
whale visiting us right there
laughs
[Music]
don't keep that one oh nice card
okay you guys all got fish on
[Music]
yo we got a nice card
stream yep
hold on to that Rod Tom
all right guys we're Switching gears a
little bit we're up here closer to shore
near the Carol forest and we got these
bass rods and we're gonna be fishing for
black bass I got something
oh yeah
not once yeah that would be a nice one
from his oh that's a nice one Nate
oh look at that that is a chunky black
bass
nice black bass
okay keep your lures away from each
other yeah
Tom that's kind of a small one you wanna
let that one go tell your buddies about
this oh I need to yeah I need the Gap
yeah
look at that that is another nice one
he dropped a big flasher under the boat
and it's bringing the school of black
bass right up to the surface
oh there's a nice ones in there
[Music]
oh gosh
that was
a big fish yeah
eating where's the hell of it
a massive halibut came up and nailed
the gym oh did he just he just popped
off
but we could see him under the boat yeah
that halibut was attacking Nathan's
Rockfish Tommy had a Cod on it was going
for that halibut was picking a fight
with everybody
that's right
holy mackerel Nathan look at the belly
on that guy this Dutch hobo size he is
Dutch Harbor's eyes
freaking let me know so I can
talk
thank you
all right guys what do you think we go
back and fish for some halibut
Ed
all right well we're gonna go try to get
some more halibut here
immediate hookup
hey there you go got a triple of course
can't ever get just one fish
Let It Go
oh yeah
I got one halibut and three cod in under
five minutes
unless somebody else wants it we'll let
it go all right
yeah big boss card
nice card
we need to go Direct Connect
don't know what's on the end of the rod
looks like a big healthy card to me
so bad
it's been really rare that we've got a
fish on and not had a triple almost
every time somebody catches something
everyone's catching something that looks
like a big Cod
oh he came off oh nice
oh you're lucky trout lure Mr stale
dirty Cod stole it
well that was a good Drift But we're
gonna move spots real quick guys you
want to try to send audio all right
this is the weirdest smell I've ever
smelled yeah do you ever taste
amazing you like that
it's kind of a fruity Latino Cola
keep him that
cause
foreign
's right there
spines there there there there sculpin's
pokiness to meat ratio is pretty bad
[Music]
oh
it's an uncommon macro I was hoping we'd
catch one
yay
that's an ABCA mackerel they don't get
much bigger than that
got a bunch of cod here so we're gonna
move around and see if we can't find us
some more halibut
oh there you go Nathan a little hell of
it
a little tiny halibut
Ed
there you go
well he's not huge but it's the end of
the day so we'll take him all right guys
how do you know it's time to stop
fishing when the fish won't sink in the
cooler anymore
yep we're done
the ocean around Onalaska can be really
temperamental and very dangerous
but man when it is on it is on this is
gorgeous It's gotta be my favorite place
in Alaska to fish
[Music]
yeah
and this is all from here yeah there's
no wind at all it's artificial because
very content
yeah
all right it's picture time we gotta lay
out all the fish get a picture of the
boys
get a little further further down
okay here is our catch
the fighting back
well George thank you so much for a
great time that was a great trip
over there
Amber and Danny are processing all of
this fish and I cannot tell you how
grateful I am I have done this enough to
appreciate what they are doing
thank you for the ride we'll see you
Saturday
we made it back to the room and it is
late we are tired so we are going to hit
the sack we've got a lot of Adventures
planned for tomorrow I'll see you in the
morning
I think we need to go get some breakfast
oh excellent
I got Loco Moco this is some good
chocolate waffles there
[Music]
there's a bunch of rustic equipment down
there
big glob of tools that have all rusted
together
it's a machinist file well you use
another there's another glob of stuff
it's all rusted together
all right there's a brass range of some
sort
take out the bullet holes right here
someone was shooting this piece of Steel
because Dutch Harbor is so remote
shipping stuff in and out of here is
extremely expensive so in this military
base closed at the end of World War II
they just left everything here and they
abandoned a lot of their equipment right
here on the beach
bit of a crankshaft to an engine
that's a bit from a car's suspension
that's a bit of leaf spring steel
oh yeah there's a big old truck axle
there the car's expensive
look at this
see that
it looks like a 50 cal it's not just a
shell
we've got this
look at that
an old fork and knife look what it says
Tommy look at that it says usn that's
the U.S Navy
big old flywheel of some sort nice bit
of sea glass
oh that is the perfect throwing Stone
oh that was perfect
machine gun bunker just sitting there in
the grass another bunker right there
okay
rain jacket made out of guys pants made
out of sea otter
that's a halibut hook look at the size
of that thing
let's do a video where we make halibut
Hooks and come back and try to catch
halibut using our traditional halibut
hooks look at that little baby rain
jacket made of guts that's a red king
crab look at the size of these things
crab raid
that is it
so this is Ballyhoo mountain right next
to the airport and it's covered in World
War II era bunkers and fortresses and
it's actually run by the National Park
Service so we're gonna hike up the
mountain and do a little exploring
oh look at this
look at these salmon berries
look at those bad boys they taste so
good
mmm look at the size of those berries
are those amazing look at all of these
they are just tons of berry bushes all
over this mountain blueberries Crow
berries looks like there's some Linden
berries
oh there's like a little bunker down
there
[Music]
that's cool
oh there's Parky squirrels inside the
building the sink right there it's
probably like a bathroom or a wash house
or something so this base was called
Fort swartzka and it had a thousand men
serving here during World War II this
was the officer's Barracks a big furnace
over there A lot of these buildings were
connected with tunnels so that men could
go to and from even when the weather was
extremely bad another little building or
something
yeah don't go in there there's tons of
nails sticking up you'll get one right
through your foot this mountain is just
full of Old World War II ruins there's
buildings there there there
you can see all these little dimples on
the hill where they dug out pill boxes
and gun emplacements they're all
overgrown with vegetation now
yeah they're just the metal bed frames
right there all the woods rotted away
and left in Rusty Nails
look at that there's a baby tarmigan
right there
see look
s good keeping your head dry yep
finished my popcorn so I just shoved in
the back of my head
oh look at this yeah it is cold in here
look how thick that steel door is
oh it's so cold in here
it's like a refrigerator in there
because of all the permafrost
look at the bullet holes in there it's
like an office in here
it's like a command bunker
yeah Tom don't slip
this is a three-story bunker you can see
there's another story down there yeah
I don't want to fall down there I don't
think I'd be able to get back up
wow look at this this is awesome
look at that
that is a beautiful view
that's cool should we go check out this
part this big rail here is where they
would Mount the giant artillery piece
this bad boy would shoot a 240 pound
projectile over 20 miles and they could
turn at 360 degrees and thanks to
observers placed around the different
Islands they could even hit ships they
couldn't see
yeah
I brought a flashlight on this trip just
so we could explore this stuff and I
left it back at the hotel I have to use
my cell phone
there's like a big circular
there's a lot of water
so you know another gun placement look
at the big ball bearings they had for
turning it around
spot for another artillery piece here
but yeah don't slip down that Cliff Tom
wait it's a stable
I mean yeah I guess
yeah
some lady forgot her glasses
if these are your glasses you left them
by a pill box in Onalaska
all right guys if we hurry quick we can
make it to the war museum and then we
can go back to the hotel and get dry and
warm
last year Mia Tommy did
he did and on that trip we hiked a
mountain over there and found a whole
bunch of bunkers we also caught a ton of
fish if you guys want to see that video
I'll put a link in the video description
below and you can check that out as well
oh dude this guy I think he's gonna give
us a ride I saw you there and I was like
is that
adjusted here just give us a ride into
town thank you it's getting I'm getting
a little soggy out there
the National Park Service has a World
War II museum here but it ain't open
all right
our buddy Justin here is to give it us a
little tour of Dutch Harbor you don't do
the survival thing
I'll tell you if you don't mind getting
kicked in the teeth by the weather this
is a beautiful beautiful place
that right there is the Onalaska
National Forest those are the ancestors
of trees planted by Russian settlers
hundreds of years ago and just about the
only trees on the island thank you so
much for the tour and the ride I really
appreciate it
pleasure meeting you
oh
it smells so good oh this is nice
last breakfast in Onalaska
fishing I think you're right the
chocolate waffles are the best
thank you
okay oh we got a ride
Amber and Danny met us at the airport
with all of our frozen fish these are 50
pound boxes so that's 150 pounds of fish
fillets
all right take it out they vacuum sealed
and labeled everything
well thanks for watching guys we hope
you enjoyed this video and I hope you
enjoy these Adventures we go on if you
want to see more of this make sure to
click subscribe to the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel thanks for watching guys
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button and you'll get notifications
thanks for watching